Hallo, guten Tag.
Guten Tag, Herr Dr. Möbbel.
Mein Name ist Ekrem Özüvalı. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Arzt und Arzt tätig.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen heute ein Aufnahmegespräch durchführen. Alles in Ordnung?
Ja, klar.
Erstmal benötige ich ein paar persönliche Daten und dann können wir weiterführen. Wie heißen Sie?
Ja, ich heiße Vipke Albrecht.
Vipke Albrecht?
Vipke.
Könnten Sie bitte Vornamen und Nachnamen langsam und deutlich buchstabieren?
Ja, okay.
Wie Wilhelm, wie Ida, wie Emil.
Bitte langsam.
Wie Wilhelm, wie Ida, wie Emil, wie Bertha, wie Kaufmann, wie Emil.
Und mein Nachname buchstabiert sich.
Albrecht, ja.
Frau Albrecht.
Ja, genau.
Frau Albrecht, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,68 Meter groß.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Entschuldigung, ich bin 45 Jahre alt.
45 Jahre alt. Wann geboren?
Wann sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin am 14.10.1978 geboren.
14.10.1978.
Okay. Wie viel wiegen Sie, Frau Albrecht?
Ich wiege 86 Kilo.
86 Kilo. Wie groß sind Sie, Frau Albrecht?
1,68 Meter.
Ja.
Wenn ich richtig verstanden bin.
Frau Albrecht, was führt Sie zu uns heute? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Herr Doktor, ich habe plötzlich ganz starke Schmerzen hier rechts in der Flanke.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich sitzen oder liegen soll.
Wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen, Frau Albrecht?
Seit etwa 1,5 Stunden, Herr Doktor. Und es wird immer schlimmer.
1,5 Stunden.
Frau Albrecht, diese Schmerzen plötzlich angefangen.
Ja, ganz plötzlich. Von einer Sekunde nach der anderen.
Dann sind die Schmerzen aktuell dauerhaft oder kampfhaft oder komptertätig.
Ja, Sie gehen nicht weg, Herr Doktor. Sie werden immer stärker.
Dauerhaft immer.
Ja.
Okay. Wie ist die Schmerzen? Wie beschreiben Sie?
Stichend, siehend, dunst, kranftig?
Stichend, ja. Und kolligartig kann ich sagen.
Stichend und kolligartig. Auch wählenförmig?
Wie sehen. Kolligartig. Es kommt im Wählen wieder ganz stark.
Okay.
Frau Albrecht, wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen? Wie beschreiben Sie auf einer Schmerzskala, wobei 0 ist kein Schmerzen?
Sind sie sehr stark Schmerzen? Wie beschreiben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Mindestens sieben, Herr Doktor. Vielleicht sogar mehr.
Ja, mindestens sieben auf einer Schmerzskala. Ich verstehe.
Frau Albrecht, wenn ich richtig verstehe, Sie haben sehr, sehr starke Schmerzen.
Brauchen Sie eine Schmerzmittel oder können Sie ein gemassene bis zum Ende aushalten?
Das brauche ich denke. Lieber eine Schmerzmittel.
Ja, ich kann Ihnen eine Schmerzmittel geben.
Frau Albrecht, haben Sie noch eine Allergie gegen etwas? Zum Beispiel Medikament oder Staub? Besonders gegen Medikamente?
Nein, ich habe nur Altenverträglichkeiten. Keine Allergie habe ich.
Okay.
Vorher haben Sie dagegen ein Medikament angenommen oder?
Nein, ich wusste gar nicht, was ich nehmen soll.
Okay. Ich gebe Ihnen eine Schmerzmittel. Ich rufe sofort an die kranken Schwestern an.
Können wir weiterführen oder?
Ja, natürlich.
Frau Albrecht, gibt es noch etwas gleichsichtiger Beschwerden?
Gleichsichtiger Beschwerden? Ich weiß nicht, was Sie damit meinen, aber ich fühle mich total fieberisch, Herr Doktor.
Ein bisschen fieberisch.
Nein, total fieberisch.
Total fieberisch.
Ich fühle mich total fieberisch, aber ich habe es nicht gemessen.
Nicht gemessen.
Ich bin ganz verschwitzt.
Keine Sorge, wir werden das alles nicht gemessen.
Frau Albrecht, ich habe diese Frage stellen, strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Ja, in den rechten Unterbauch.
In den rechten Unterbauch.
Also gibt es noch andere Beschwerden? Vielleicht zum Beispiel Schüttelfrost, Schweißaufbruch?
Wie fühlen Sie sich?
Ich bin ganz verschwitzt. Ich weiß nicht, ob es für Sie wichtig ist.
Fühlen Sie sich nur fieberisch? Ja, okay.
Ich bin ganz verschwitzt.
Frau Albrecht, haben Sie Übelkeit oder Übrigung?
Ja, mir ist ein bisschen übel, Herr Doktor. Nicht ein bisschen. Mir ist richtig schlecht, Herr Doktor.
Richtig schlecht.
Sehr.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Ja.
Und Erbrüchen?
Keine Erbrüchen.
Seit gestern.
Seit gestern?
Anderthalb Stunden.
Ja, ja.
Frau Albrecht, haben Sie noch andere Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Beim Wasserlassen?
Haben Sie eine Veränderung bemerkt? Farbe oder Richt?
Mein Urin ist dunkler, Herr Doktor. Fast rötlich.
Urin ist dunkler.
Fast rötlich.
Rote Farbe. Hat rote Farbe.
Rote Farbe. Haben Sie diese Befunde heute bemerkt?
Heute?
Heute.
Könnte es Blut sein, Herr Doktor?
Ja, natürlich kann es sein. Aber wir werden alles überprüfen.
Es sah irgendwie komisch aus.
Vorher haben Sie eine Situation bemerkt beim Wasserlassen?
Wasserlassen? Mein Befunde ist ganz in Bechwerden.
Nein, nein. Farbeveränderung beim Urin.
Das habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Haben Sie nur heute bemerkt? Vorher haben Sie gar nicht bemerkt diese Befunde?
Haben Sie noch Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Nein.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Ich habe kaum Appetit, Herr Doktor. Keinen.
Keinen Appetit? Nichts essen. Ich könnte nichts essen.
Okay. Wie viel Wasser trinken Sie täglich? Gibt es eine bestimmte Menge oder?
Ich habe nicht gerechnet, aber nicht so viel.
Vielleicht nicht ausreichend. Aber vielleicht ein Liter.
Ein Liter. Aber außer Wasser habe ich Tee oder Kaffee getrunken.
Meistens täglich Kaffee oder Wasser trinken Sie.
Ich kann nicht gerechnet, Herr Doktor. Ich habe viel Schmerzen.
Aber ich denke, ich trinke nicht ausreichend Wasser.
Ich würde gerne wissen, wie ernern Sie sich?
Aber was ist mit Fleisch oder Gemüse oder Vegane?
Ich normalernern.
Was ist denn normal? Ist es mit Fleisch oder?
Nein, nicht täglich. Aber alle zwei Tage Fleisch oder Kaffee oder gar nichts.
Okay. Ich verstehe.
Frau Andres.
Wie gesagt, habe ich Unterträglichkeiten, Herr Doktor.
Herr Doktor.
Unfertiglichkeiten.
Ja, Glutenunfertiglichkeiten habe ich.
Und dann bekomme ich krampfartige Bauchschmerzen.
Und auf fetthaltiges Essen muss ich verzichten.
Außer dieser Atem, außer dieser ernähre ich mich normal.
Aber darauf muss ich achten, natürlich.
Ja, okay. Ich habe das notiert. Danke für die Information.
Sehr wichtige Information für uns.
Frau Andres, leiden Sie irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen?
Erkrankungen, zum Beispiel Arteriellhypertonie oder Zuckerkrankheit oder gibt es noch etwas?
Chronisch habe ich seit 20 Jahren Morbuskron, Herr Doktor.
Morbuskron, seit 20 Jahren Morbuskron.
Haben Sie schon Regelmäßig kontrolliert?
Ja, natürlich.
Bei Ihrem Arzt?
Und vielleicht möchten Sie wissen, vor 10 Jahren wurde mir ein Teil des Dünndans entfällt.
Deswegen.
Seit wann haben Sie gesagt?
Vor 10 Jahren.
Seit 20 Jahren haben Sie Morbuskron bekannt.
Vor 10 Jahren wurden Sie einmal operiert wegen Morbuskron.
Wenn ich richtig verstanden habe.
Frau Andres, wissen Sie, was hat Sie bei der Operation gemacht?
Wie bitte?
Was wurde bei dieser Operation durchgeführt?
Ich kann nicht verstehen.
Ein Teil des Dünndans entfällt?
Ein Teil des Dünndans.
Dünndans.
Nicht Dünndans, aber Dünndans.
Das war eine Komplikation oder haben Sie etwas?
Zum Glück war es keine Komplikation.
Okay.
Gibt es noch andere Operationen oder Kronkrankheiten?
Nein.
Nicht bekannt. Okay. Ich habe das notiert.
Und Frau Albrecht, nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente?
Ja, je nach choux, meine ich Morbuskronchou, nehme ich Bouda Zonit.
Aber die genaue Dosis weiß ich gerade nicht.
Ja, Bouda Zonit, nur bei Choux.
Je nach Choux, ja.
Okay.
Und manchmal Mineralstoffe.
Gibt es etwas Besonderes, Stoffe? Zum Beispiel Kalzomagnesium?
Gemischt. Okay.
Es gibt keine Besten.
Keine Besten.
Stoffe.
Man kann einfach bei Dium oder bei Rosmann kaufen.
Ja, allgemein Vitaminsstoffe. Nehmen Sie.
Okay.
Ich notiere.
Haben Sie schon gesagt, Sie haben eine glutenunverträglichkeit?
Haben Sie noch Allergien gegen etwas?
Wie gesagt habe ich keine Allergien, Doktor.
Okay.
Gegen irgendwelche.
Sind Sie vorgeimpft, Frau Albrecht?
Ja, auch gegen Corona bin ich geimpft.
Okay.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit irgendwo hin gereist?
Gereist?
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit gemacht?
Nein, nein, Doktor.
Okay.
Frau Albrecht, rauchen Sie?
Nein, Doktor, niemals.
Super.
Wozu wissen?
Kurz hören, Frau Albrecht. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nein.
Gar nicht.
Super.
Bitte nehmen Sie nicht persönlich.
Haben Sie einmal schon Drogen ausprobiert?
Nein, Doktor, sehe ich so aus.
Nein, gar nicht. Das ist eine Routinefrage, Frau Albrecht.
Bitte nehmen Sie persönlich. Das sind ganz allgemeine Fragen.
Frau Albrecht, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, leben sie noch, aber sie haben manche Probleme, gesundheitliche Probleme.
Mein Vater hatte vor zwei Jahren Covid.
Seitdem hat er Lungenprobleme und bekommt bei jeder Bewegung Luftnot.
Herr Doktor.
Lungenfibros?
Ich weiß nicht, wie Sie meinen, aber Lungenprobleme hat er.
Beim Bewegung braucht er immer Sauerstoff?
Ja, ohne Sauerstoff. Er muss immer Pause machen.
Ich verstehe. Okay, ich werde das notiert.
Das belastet uns sehr, Herr Doktor.
Ja, ich verstehe. Es tut mir leid.
Und bei der Mutter gibt es irgendwelche Erkrankungen?
Sie hat seit Jahren auch Darmentzündung, Herr Doktor. Seit Jahren.
Seit Jahren?
Ja, Darmentzündung.
Darmentzündung. Gibt es?
Die Ärzte nennen das, ich denke, Colitis ussarosa.
Ja, ein bestimmter Diagnos ist Colitis ussarosa bei Ihnen.
Okay, Colitis ussarosa.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Meine Schwester ist sehr zuständig, Herr Doktor. Zwanghaft. Alles muss sauber sein.
Zwanghaft.
Ja, das belastet uns auch sehr.
Zwangssturm.
Was für eine Krankheit ist das, Herr Doktor?
Sie beschreiben eine Schwangsstörung bei ihrer Schwester.
Schwangsstörung ist ein psychologisches Problem.
Ja, am besten. Es wäre besser, wenn Sie einen Spezialisten oder einen Psychologen einen Termin vereinbaren oder beschreiben könnten.
Das machen wir, Herr Doktor. Danke für Ihre Empfehlung.
Frau Obrecht, was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Gärtnereimeisterin, Herr Doktor. Ich arbeite in Gärtnerei.
Gärtnerei?
Gärtnerei, natürlich.
Gärtnerei. Okay. Sind Sie verheiratet, Frau Obrecht?
Ja, Herr Doktor, ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, einen Sohn. Er ist 16 Jahre alt und gesund.
Ist er gesund? Ja, gesund. Alles gut.
Frau Obrecht, ich bin nun mit meinen Fragen fertig. Haben Sie noch Fragen an mich?
Was haben Sie für mich?
Ja, ich habe einen Verdacht auf Harnsteinleiden. Aber das ist nur eine Vermutung.
Dann können wir ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Ich werde zuerst einen körperlichen Untersuchungen durchführen.
Dann werde ich einen Blut für das Labo abnehmen.
Dann werde ich einen Bauchröntgen und einen Bauchultraschall planen.
Oh Gott, was heißt das?
Was meinen Sie? Ultraschall oder Röntgen?
Ultraschall. Ultraschall ist eine sehr moderne Untersuchungsmethode. Schmerzfrei.
Okay, Abzache, es tut mir nicht leid. Machen Sie weiter, Herr Doktor.
Okay, okay. Bitte warten Sie hier.
Mein Mann ist auf Geschäftsreise und mein Sohn ist allein zu Hause.
Ich muss ihn eigentlich von der Schule abholen.
Gibt es jemand, der Ihnen helfen kann?
Ich überlege, Herr Doktor. Ich bin ein bisschen verwirrt.
Weil ich hierbleiben soll, bin ich ein bisschen verwirrt. Danke.
Ich kann unseren Sozialdienst anrufen.
Nein, nein, ich brauche ihn nicht. Ich kann es selbst erledigen.
Okay, bis dann.
Link, Link.
Hallo, guten Tag. Ich bin Frau Müller aus dem Labor.
Frau Gerhild hat Chrombocytinwerte 15.200 pro Mikro.
200 pro Mikro Liter.
Danke für die Information, Frau Müller.
Schönen Tag. Auf Wiedersehen. Tschüss.
Herzlichen Willkommen, Herr Özgüval.
Ja, guten Tag. Woher kommen Sie, Herr Özgüval?
Ich komme aus der Türkei. Ich lebe seit drei Jahren in Deutschland.
Warum sind Sie in Deutschland gekommen?
Ich bin ein Poltischen Guru.
Warum laufen Sie? Das ist komisch.
Wie bitte?
Ja, es ist sehr komisch, aber das ist so.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Sind Sie normalerweise in der Türkei Facharzt?
Ja, ich bin in der Türkei als Urologie Facharzt tätig.
Bei einem Krankenhaus.
Seit 10 Jahren bin ich Urologie Facharzt.
Aber seit 3 Jahren bin ich Arbathlos.
Ich lerne Deutsch und möchte wieder in Deutschland arbeiten.
Würden Sie wieder als Urologin arbeiten oder möchten Sie in einem anderen Bereich arbeiten?
Ja, natürlich möchte ich wieder in Deutschland als Urologin arbeiten.
Ich habe viel Forschung, besonders über Uro-Unkologen.
Und dann möchte ich weiter mit meiner Forschung fahren.
Okay, ich verstehe. Was haben Sie heute für uns?
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten, Frau Wiebke Albrecht, 45 Jahre alt, geboren am 14.10.1979.
Sie ist 1,68 Meter groß und 86 Kilo.
Frau Albrecht stellt sich heute bei uns wegen einer halben Stunde plötzlich angefangenen Stärken und Schmerzen im rechten Flank.
Die Schmerzen sind dauerhaftig, stechend und kolikartig.
Nach Angaben der Patienten sind die Schmerzen wellenformig und kolikartig.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 7 von 10 auf einer Schmerzskala.
Als Begleitsymptomen beschreibt sie, dass sie sich immer fiebrig fühlt.
Seit anderthalb Stunden hat sie Übelkeit, aber ohne Erbrüche.
Die Schmerzen sind schmerzhaft.
Die Vegetative ist sehr schmerzhaft.
Seit anderthalb Stunden ist sie dunkel und hat rote Übrigen.
Was bedeutet rote Übrigen?
Rote Übrigen sind Hämatür.
Bei den Vorerkrankungen...
Noch andere Beschwerden bei der Masse sind Hämatür.
Hämatür und sie beschreibt schmerzhaftige Wasalasen.
Was bedeutet schmerzhaftige Wasalasen?
Dysurie.
Wie oft geht sie zum Wasalasen? Wie viele Üren hat sie?
Ich habe nicht gefragt. Die Patienten waren ein bisschen stressig.
Ich verstehe. Aber wenn die Patientin eine Mixionbeschwerde hat,
dann sollen sie andere bezüglich Mixionbeschwerden Fragen stellen.
Wie oft gehen sie?
Ich möchte fragen, aber die Patienten waren ein bisschen...
Ich verstehe. Sie hatten sehr starke Schmerzen.
Trotz der Medikamente.
Wegen der Schmerzen.
Eigentlich habe ich gefragt.
Vorerkrankung beschreibt eine Morbus Crohn seit 20 Jahren.
Ist das wichtig?
Ja, natürlich sehr wichtig.
Warum?
Meine Verdachtdiagnose ist Harnstein.
Gibt es einen Zusammenhang zwischen Morbus Crohn und Harnstein?
Morbus Crohn ist ein Prädisposanfaktor.
Prädisposanerkrankung für den Harnwegstein.
Warum?
Weil bei Morbus Crohn betroffene Teil ist Dünn.
Illium des Teiles Dündarps.
Illium ist zuständig mit Fett- und Kassiumabsorbtion.
Wegen dieser Probleme hat Illium nicht gut Kassium und Fettsäure absorbt.
Deswegen ist Dündarps Konzentration des Fetts und unverdauerten Fettsäuren sehr hoch.
Deswegen verwenden wir Oxalat.
Fettsäure verwenden wir Oxalat.
Dann wird Kassium im Daumen frei.
Deswegen wird die Blutkassiumkonzentration sehr hoch.
Bei Nephron oder tubularer Kanal wird immer ein Kassium-Oxalat-Kristall bestellt.
Deswegen ist dieses Kristall ein Stein.
Okay.
Sie können weiter machen.
Vor zehn Jahren war bei einem einen Darmentfernung.
Dürkifürt.
Total alle Darmentfernung?
Teil.
Ein Teil Dünndarmentfernung.
Dürkifürt.
Nicht total.
Nur ein Teil.
Ich denke nur ein Teil Illium.
Als Medikament nimmt sie bei der Schub Hudezonit und ein paar Mineralstofftabletten ein.
Allergie war in einer Allergie nicht bekannt.
Sie hatte eine glutenunverträglichkeit gegen fetthaltiges Essen.
Und glutenunverträglichkeit gegen ...
Unverträglichkeit gegen abfettiges Essen.
Ja, gegen abfettiges Essen.
Ich dachte glutenunterfetthaltiges Essen gegen Unverträglichkeit ganz anders.
Sie ist vollgeimpft. Keine Reise.
Gesichten. Nutzung, Konsum, Alkohol, Nikotin und Drogenkonsum Hude von and.
Bei der Familienanalyse ergab ...
Bei der Vater leidet eine chronische Lungenkrankheit, aber die bestimmte Diagnose ist nicht bekannt.
Die Mutter leidet eine Darmentzündung. Sie beschreibt das Cholitis ulcerosa.
Bei der Schwester ist eine Schwankstörung bekannt. Sie ist Gartner.
Sie hat schon einen Psychiater besucht.
Ich habe nicht gefragt. Aber ich empfehle Ihnen einen psychiatrischen Konsul.
Dann sagen Sie Verdacht auf Schwankstörungen. Sagen Sie nicht direkt Schwankstörungen.
Verdacht auf Schwankstörungen. Ja. Okay.
Momentan hat sie keine bestimmte Diagnose.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Die Frau beschwert über ihre Schwester beschwerten. Sie möchten alle sauber machen.
Sie beschäftigt sich tagsüber mit sauber zu machen.
Aber sie hat momentan keine Psychiater besucht.
Deswegen wissen wir nicht genau, ob sie eine Schwankstörung hat.
Manche Leute sind sehr, sehr ... Manche Leute möchten sehr sauber sein.
Aber trotzdem haben sie keine Schwankstörungen. Ja?
Ja. Darf ich so sagen?
Darf ich so sagen? Sie berichteten, dass bei ihrer Schwester eine Schwankstörung gibt.
Nein, du kannst einfach sagen, bei der Schwester Verdacht auf Schwankstörungen.
Ja, bei der Schwester Verdacht auf Schwankstörungen. Ja, das bedeutet ... Ich weiß es nicht genau. Aber ich verbiere es.
Ja, bei der Schwester Verdacht auf Schwankstörungen. Ganz kurz. Ja, ganz kurz.
Vielen Dank für die Information. Bei der Schwester Verdacht auf Schwankstörungen.
Ja, bei der Vorerkrankung ergab sich Verdacht auf Schwankstörungen bei der Schwester,
bei der Schwester Ülterativkolytis bei der Mutter und Verdacht auf Lungenfibrose bei dem Vater.
Ja, Verdacht auf Lungenfibrose. In einem Satz sagen Sie alle Familienanamnese.
Die Familienanamnese ergab bei dem Vater, Verdacht auf Lungenfibrose, bei der Mutter, Verdacht auf Kolitis-Ulterose.
Nein, sie sagt Ulterative Kolitis.
Verdacht auf Darmentzündung. Nein, nein.
Ihre Patientin sagt direkt Kolitis-Ulterose. Dann brauchen Sie keinen Verdacht.
Okay, okay. Ja, bei der Schwester Verdacht auf Schwankstörungen.
Sie ist generell verheiratet. Sie hat einen Sohn. Der Sohn ist gesund.
Aufgrund der Anamnese habe ich den Verdacht auf Urolithiasis.
Die Pheranthaldiagnostik kommen, Pyronephritis und ein akutes Schub des Morbus Crohn.
Sie sind jetzt in Wechseljahren?
Nein, sie ist 45 Jahre alt.
Wann hatten Sie das letzte Morbidatum?
Habe ich nicht gefragt.
Hat Sie Beschwerde im genekologischen Amnesen?
Leider habe ich nicht gefragt.
Aber was denken Sie? Ob diese Frage wichtig ist?
Für die Pheranthaldiagnostik habe ich den Pyronephritis gedacht.
Wegen einer Infektion. Diese Weise ist sehr wichtig.
Sie hatte regelmäßig eine Periode. Eine chronische Infektion.
Haben Sie meine Frage gehört?
Meine Frage ist, ob genekologische Anamnese bei dieser Falle wichtig ist?
Sie ist 45 Jahre alt.
Für die Niederstein ist das nicht wichtig.
Nein, das ist nicht wichtig.
Sie hat Flankschmerzen, aber die schmerzen zutrauen in den Unterbauch.
Und in den rechten Unterbauch.
Eine genekologische Pathologie.
Normalerweise ist genekologische Anamnese nicht wichtig.
Bei aller Fälle, aber bei Urolithiasis, bei Apandesitis, ist es wichtig.
Weil es die Beschwerden gibt.
Sie haben recht.
Deswegen sollen Sie diese Frage nicht vergessen.
Normalerweise ist die Steinschmerzen immer kolikartig.
Der Patient sagt, dass die Schmerzen dauerhaft sind.
Deswegen muss der Arzt oder Ärztin diese Frage stellen.
Dauerhaft Schmerzen bei der Nierenstein oder der Harnwegstein ist nicht möglich.
Bei der Harnwegstein Schmerzen ist immer kolikartig.
Aber kolikartig bedeutet manchmal sehr sehr stark und manchmal sehr wenig.
Aber trotzdem kann man immer Schmerzen haben.
Bei der Renalkollegin ist die Patientin in der Zwischenzeit ganz normal.
Dann kommt wieder ein neuer Attack und die Schmerzen sind sehr hoch.
Aber inzwischen ist der Attack normal und die Schmerzskala ist nur.
Okay.
Aber es gibt auch Hematöri.
Dauerhaft, aber Schmerzen sind nicht dauerhaft.
Aber sie haben recht.
Genekologische Anamnese ist sehr wichtig.
Weitere Diagnostik?
Meine Diagnostik ist ein Pelnifritis und ein akuter Schub des Morbus-Krons.
Bei der Prozedere werde ich zunächst eine körperliche Untersuchung machen.
Dann werde ich Blut für das Labor abnehmen.
Bei der Blutlabour werde ich Blutbild, Leber und Nierenwerte und CAP und Entsündung werten.
Und Ürungsstatus sowie eine Ürungsstatus und eine Ürinkultur überprüfen.
Noch weitere Diagnostik werde ich einen röntgen Bauch und einen Bauchunterschall empfehlen.
So wie einen bürokratischen Konsil werde ich antworten.
Gegenwünsche ich eine CT ohne Kontrastmittel.
Bei der Therapie beginnt die erste Maßnahme mit Full-Sickage-Suppe.
Ich empfehle Analgetik und Antiemethik.
Wenn die Ürinkultur positiv ist, kann man Antibiotik auch anbieten.
Die Prozedere sind die gleiche wie die Urologie.
Sie sind Urologin, deswegen erwarte ich von dir eine weitere Therapie.
Wenn Sie diese Falle in der Prüfung bekommen, sagen Sie uns alle.
Sie bekommen viele Fragen, weil wir Urologin sind.
Meine Verdachtdiagnose bestimmt ist ein Handleiterstein.
Aber der erste Schritt ist, wo steht der Stein?
In der Niere, Handleiter, Blase oder Retra.
In der Niere, aber wo?
In der Mitte oder unter der Hand?
Jede Therapie ist anders.
Vielleicht im Nierenbecken.
Die Möglichkeiten sind anders.
Die Ürkultur ist anders.
Die Oberhandleiter-Therapie ist anders.
Die Mitte ist anders.
Die Unterhandleiter-Therapie ist anders.
Der Stein ist anders.
Was ist das große Dessteins?
Das große Dessteins ist sehr wichtig, wenn die unter 7 mm.
Die Therapie ist nur konservativ.
Füßigkeit und Energie-Tüpfung und zum Beispiel eine Alphablocker-Tamflosien-spontan-Mikroassierung.
Die Spontanmikroassierung ist genug.
In einem Monat 18% des Steins wegführen.
Über 7 mm ist die Lokalisation sehr wichtig.
Wenn diese Steine in Handleiter sind,
sollen sie eine Ureterorenoskopie durchführen.
Und einen Stand einnehmen.
Wenn über 7 mm Stein ist,
kann es in der Nierenbecken-Mikroassierung
eine Extra Shockwave-Lithotherapsie sein.
Über 7 mm Stein werden sie eine Ureterorenoskopie und Intracorporellithotherapsie versuchen.
Wenn die Steine über 7 mm und 2 cm sind,
können sie eine flexible Ureterorenoskopie und einen Laser machen.
Aber über 2 cm gibt es nur eine Therapiemöglichkeit für die Percutane-Nephroditotome.
Vielen Dank für die klare Erklärung, Herr Özübal.
Haben Sie noch andere wichtige Informationen für mich?
Ja, ich habe noch eine sehr wichtige Information für Sie.
Frau Müller hat mich angerufen.
Frau Müller hat mich angerufen, dass die Traumbozytwerte 15.200 pro Milliliter sind.
15.200 pro Milliliter Traumbozyten.
Diese Worte sind deutlich erneuert und entspricht der Traumbozytophen.
Die Ursachen der Traumbozytophen sind Leukämie,
plastische Anämie, Vitamin B12 und Fosäuremangel,
Infektionkrankheiten, Hypersplenismus,
Lebasrose, künstliche Herzklappen und
Welchen Symptom erwarten Sie bei Traumbozytophen?
Wir erwarten Hämatomen, Nasenblutung, Samflaschblutung, Spontanblutung etwas.
Und Hirnblutung.
Wie können Sie diese Patienten behandeln?
Die Behandlung ist Grunderkrankung, Therapie und Traumbozyttransfusion.
Haben Sie schon diese Patienten untersucht?
Nein, ich habe diese Patienten nicht gesehen.
Dann was sollen Sie machen?
Ich muss diese Patienten einmal untersuchen.
Dann können wir weiter über diese Patienten sprechen.
Sie sollen hier vorsichtig sein.
Der Prüfer fragt, wie können Sie diese Patienten behandeln?
Das ist ein Fall.
Ich habe so gefragt.
Aber normalerweise können Sie fragen, wie behandelt man Traumbozytophen?
Dann können Sie einfach sagen, Hauptsache ist Grunderkrankung.
Aber wir können Traumbozyten-Transfusion oder Traumbozyten-Konzentration geben.
Aber wenn Sie diese Patientenbehandlung fragen,
sollen Sie sagen, ich sollte zuerst die Patienten untersuchen,
die Rappenwerte überprüfen, die Ursachen finden und die bestmögliche Therapie planen.
Danach behandle ich diese Patienten.
Manchmal macht der Prüfer oder die Prüferinnen so.
Vielen Dank für die Information.
Ich habe meine Fragen über die Regiomessik-Prognose geliefert, aber ich habe sie vergessen zu fragen.
Das kann sein.
In diesem Fall war alles gut.
Meine Frage zu den Mixion-Werte ist wichtig.
Ich habe die Anwesenden nicht beantwortet.
Ekrem, Sie wollen eine Ersatzung von mir.
Ich lasse Sie nur, damit Sie in die Struktur gehen.
Ich sage es Ihnen, damit Sie nicht zu viel machen.
Sie müssen die Fragen nach der genaue Frage genauer fragen.
Die Patienten können sie vergessen.
Sie können nicht sagen.
Sie müssen die Fragen genauer fragen.
Sie können nicht sagen, dass sie nicht zu viel machen.
Das ist die Frage, die ich hier habe.
Aber das ist so wichtig.
Wir müssen die Patienten nicht einfach vergessen.
Wir müssen sie nicht wissen.
Ich kann die Frage nicht genauer fragen.
Ich muss die Struktur der Sitzung von der Lesung sagen.
Das ist so.
Ich kann Ihnen die Anwesenden nicht beantworten.
Ich habe Sie schon in der Anamnesstunde gefragt.
Nesi, bitte.
Ich werde Sie kurz aufrufen.
Nesi, sind Sie hier?
Sie sind heute nicht hier.
Okay.
Sie können es sagen.
Sie können es besonders in der Akut-Coronavirus-Syndrom sagen.
Aber Sie müssen nicht zu viel über die anderen Schmerzen sagen.
Sie können es in der Akut-Coronavirus-Syndrom sagen.
Sie können es schon in der Weiter Diagnostics sagen.
Wir haben es in der Akut-Coronavirus-Syndrom gelernt.
Ich bin aber nicht in der Akut-Coronavirus-Syndrom beschäftigt.
Aber es wird gesagt, dass es in der Forschung auch in der Akut-Coronavirus-Syndrom geben kann.
Danke.
Ich möchte Sie verabschieden.
In der Klinik wird es in der Akut-Coronavirus-Syndrom gesagt.
Als Assistent war ich dann nicht in der Akut-Coronavirus-Syndrom.
Es wurde immer wieder in der Akut-Coronavirus-Syndrom gesagt.
Danke.
Es wird gesagt, dass alles in der Hand ist.
Ob es ein Ultraschall oder ein Röntgen ist,
es wird nicht so beeindruckend, wenn man in die Klinik einsteigt.
Es wird gesagt, dass alles in der Hand ist.
Danke.
Sie haben sich vielleicht verletzt oder haben eine schwere Sache angehoben.
Dann ist es das erste Mal oder hatten Sie schon früher eine Symptome?
Sie können Sie genau beschreiben.
Wie ist es, auf einer Schmerzskala?
Sie haben eine Symptome, eine Schmerzmitteleinigenome, die Sie haben.
Sie können Sie dann einfach in die Schmerzmitteleinigenome beantworten.
Wenn Sie sagen, dass Sie eine schwere Schmerzmitteleinigung haben,
können Sie das sofort in der Anfangsrunde beantworten.
Aber in der Anfangsrunde kann man nicht sagen, dass Sie eine Schwere haben.
Dann kann man diese Reaktion auch in der Anfangsrunde beantworten.
Das ist eine halbe Stunde, bis Sie die Schmerzmitteleinigung haben.
Sie haben eine Schmerzmitteleinigung, die Sie schon vorhin nicht haben.
Deswegen ist es nicht sinnvoll, einen Fertig-Faktor, einen Lindert-Faktor zu fragen.
Eine halbe Stunde, bis Sie die Schmerzmitteleinigung beantworten.
Es ist kein großes Verhalten zu fragen, aber Sie können es normalerweise nicht beantworten.
Dann kann man die Fragen der Schmerzmitteleinigung beantworten.
Ich frage Sie hier.
Ich frage Sie hier, nicht in der Vagatet-Vanamnes-Kasse.
Die Schmerzmitteleinigung beantworten Sie sofort.
Denn diese sind auch oft gesehen.
In der Örologik.
Dann frage ich Sie zuerst.
Sie haben ein Problem?
Dann bezeichne ich Sie.
Sie haben eine Schmerzmitteleinigung.
Sie sind weder normal vom Schmerz oder nicht normal vom Schmerz,
cheating oder Pferde?
Ich habe alle Fragen über die Mixion gefragt.
Die Kanzlerin hat alle Fragen über die Mixion.
Deswegen ist es wichtig, diese Fragen zu fragen.
Dann habe ich das Problem von Stoolgang gefragt.
Natürlich kann man das hier auch fragen.
Man kann es auch hier fragen.
Aber ich habe es hier gefragt.
Denn es heißt Fibrik.
Wir fragen in jedem Fall, dass es eine Analyse gibt.
Was ist hier wichtig?
Gynäkologische Analyse.
Denn das ist relativ wichtig.
Bei uns ist es ein Patient, der 45 Jahre alt ist.
Wir haben viele Frauen, die immer nur in der Meloposie sind.
Einige sind nicht so.
Da sind sie nicht so.
Denn in diesen Fällen sind sie wichtig.
Deswegen müssen wir die Gynäkologische Analyse in einem 45 Jahre alten Patient fragen.
Wenn sie die Analyse nicht mehr in der Meloposie haben,
können sie sich nicht mehr in der Meloposie verabreiten.
Sie können sich nicht mehr in der Meloposie verabreiten.
Das kann sein, dass sie nicht mehr in der Meloposie sind.
Wir fragen diese Fragen.
Warum?
Es gibt viele Fragen, die wir hier fragen.
Das stimmt.
Denn wir hatten uns schon vor, dass wir den Patienten nicht mehr fragen würden.
Was ist passiert?
Erfarum hat gesagt, dass wir ihn nicht mehr in der Meloposie verabreiten können.
Ich verstehe, dass Sie sich um Ihre Schwester sorgen.
Aber leider habe ich Ihre Schwester nicht untersucht.
Ich empfehle Ihnen, dass Ihre Schwester Ihre Hausarztin besucht,
um eine richtige Diagnose und bestmögliche Therapie zu erhalten.
Ich möchte mich über etwas fragen, das mir am meisten anstrengt.
Was ist ein Psycholog?
Mein Altersschulprime ist leider nicht richtig.
Du kannst es auf Google Translate schreiben und dort lesen.
Ich habe das vor ein paar Mal gemacht.
Ich habe es 20-30 Mal gemacht, aber ich kann es nicht richtig sagen.
Ich nenne es Psychiatrie.
Aber sie nennen es Psychiatrie.
Ich kann es nicht wirklich sagen.
Aber wenn ich das sage, verstehen sie die andere Seite.
Deswegen habe ich mich nicht so sehr aufgetauscht.
Psychologen nennen es Psychiatrie direkt Scholedoch.
Scholedoch, das ist ein Scholedoch-Holythiasis.
Sie nennen es so in der Karte.
Aber ich sehe hier, dass sie es als Scholedoch-Holythiasis nennen.
Aber die Interimmedizin nennt es Scholedoch.
Ich kann es so sagen, dass es keine P-Linie gibt.
Psychologen, Psychiatrie.
Aber ich sehe hier, dass sie es als Scholedoch nennen.
Aber wir hören es nicht.
Sie verstehen es auf der anderen Seite.
Ich kann es so sagen.
Da es mit Lungenfibrosis geht,
haben die Vertreter diese Frage geschrieben,
weil sie oft bei Covid-Komplikationen sind.
Oder wie hat ein Patient das verstanden?
Wenn man z.B. eine Zip-D-Frage fragt,
dann ist es nicht so, dass es keine P-Linie gibt.
Ich habe das schon gesagt.
Covid-Komplikationen haben lange Zeit andere Tatsachen.
Was kann man da sagen?
Ist es denn Covid-19?
Covid-19 ist normalerweise vorbei,
aber es hat auch noch andere Tatsachen.
Wie moisturizing Lüften und
wie leistungsfähig die Lage sind.
Oder wie sie sagen?
Was ist das?
Lungenfibrosis ist so ein Symbol,
Ich habe so etwas von Fibrosis geschrieben.
Ein Hörer hat etwas gesagt, das habe ich nicht gehört.
Ich habe es gesagt, Meheracin.
Long Covid ist in Deutschland verwendet.
Ich habe eine Serie gesehen, die der Bergdoktor, vielleicht wisst ihr es,
da haben sie das in einer Folge gemacht.
Die Patientin war wie du gesagt hast.
Aber dort haben sie nicht die Deutsch-Sache, sondern die Englisch-Sache gesagt.
Wenn wir das so sagen, wird es wohl jeder verstehen.
Ja, das ist Long Covid.
Sie haben das so gefragt.
Was haben sie gefragt?
Was sind das?
Was sind die Symptome?
Ich habe so etwas von Fibrosis geschrieben.
Und noch ein Punkt, Herr Professor.
In Bons hat man direkt gesagt, dass man einen Flank schmieren soll.
Aber wirklich, dass man einen Flank schmieren soll,
würde man einen Flank schmieren?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Das ist ein Fall, das ich nicht richtig verstehe.
Wie soll man das sagen?
Wie soll man das sagen, Meheracin?
Wenn man es so sagt, muss man sich fragen,
wo genau haben sie in der Mitte oder in der Lateralseite gehen?
Oder in der rechten Seite oder in der linken Seite?
In der rechten Seite oder in der linken Seite?
Das kann man nicht direkt so beantworten.
Vielleicht sagt man etwas wie, dass man sich einen Flank schmieren soll.
Dann fragt man sich, wo genau haben sie diese Schmierin in der Mitte,
in der rechten Seite oder in der linken Seite?
Dann sagt man, in der rechten Seite.
Dann sagst du, dass du einen Flank schmierst.
Wenn man die Hände anbietet, ist es nicht ein Problem.
Aber wenn man es nicht anbietet, ist es schwierig.
Ja.
Ich habe es bei diesem Patient in der gleichen Stelle gesagt.
Harnstein-Lieden.
In der zweiten Stelle habe ich Urethritiasis geschrieben.
Weil wir nicht genau wo die Hände sind,
habe ich Urethritiasis geschrieben, um die Genesung zu haben.
Die Differenzia Diagnose kann man als Pure Lenephritis bezeichnen.
Akute Schub des Morbons Crohn's.
Manche Leute nennen es Appendicitis.
Rhexite G, Unthebauch-Schmerz, das ist der Ausstrahl.
Das kann man so bezeichnen.
Und weil man eine Frau ist, kann man es so bezeichnen,
wie Adnexitis, Ovarian Torsion, Extrothering Gravitate.
Man kann es von diesen sagen.
Welchen du dir lieberst, zu sagen?
So.
Ich habe es von Pure Lenephritis und Akute Schub gesagt.
Aber es gibt es von allen.